Austin.
It's good to be home, honestly.
I don't come here enough.
I'm back in my hometown...
...and I've got these three new friends from the city...
...who've never been out into the wilderness.
I wanna introduce them to nature...
...because it's been such an important part of my life.
Being in nature, how's it make you feel?
It makes me feel adventurous.
Let's go explore.
Yeah, nice!
Free.
That is the definition of freedom right there, right?
Calm.
Do you hear that?
Somehow, we overlook nature's perfection all the time and we trash it.
You're telling me it makes you happy.
It makes you feel peaceful and calm.
That's something worth protecting.
These bottles are important because these will not go in the landfill like the boxes.
This is our birthright.
It is your birthright to feel calm and peace.
It is your birthright to feel happy and free.
And that's up to your generation and my generation...
...to leave nothing but footprints.